what's it like working with Sylvester
Stallone I mean I know and you can't be
like it's great yeah I really like it
yeah he's I I enjoy the collaborative
experience with him I think he I was
surprised at how open and and present he
was I don't know what I expected yeah
but I guess my expect in general I keep
my expectations low in my hopes High and
um he lived up to hopes oh that's great
left expectations behind he's great
I you know he's he just turned 76. wow
and he still shows up to work every day
and he's like trying to make everything
as good as he can yeah he's present and
he's and he's doing his best work and
it's cool to watch him do that thing
where he just like turns it on yeah and
you're like that's why you're a [ __ ]
movie star yeah yeah like that is I'm I
like I'm in it yeah you put you make it
easy to like to work with you yeah
um yeah he's been really fun yeah the
little bit I've gotten to do with you
know like work on a show with big big
stars like you know like for instance
like for me James Khan working with
James Khan on elf and he just passed
away yeah and it was that was you know
there's I've met lots and lots of people
that I really admire and it's been a bit
of a letdown I mean it's never like it's
never been absolutely horrible you know
but it's but there have been people who
are like oh that's too bad that guy's
kind of a dick or whatever
whereas James Khan was just like
everything you'd want a James con to be
just like your ass huh no he didn't slap
you did not slap my ass that's not what
I want out of a jeans that's not what
you want pure James Khan oh yeah they
don't have our dear well we all have
ourselves we all just want to make a
good uh hey good job out there and then
you know there's a pat on the like a
little too hard yeah yeah like yeah how
that hurt a little bit but I deserved it
right right but then it lingers and
you're kind of like Ah that's it I
deserve it yeah yeah the guy from
rollerball I can still feel it
um because you have that rollerball
power no he just was really and it was
funny because like he you know he wanted
you know he's a big movie star and he's
doing this you know Silly Christmas
movie
but all the scenes were like me Will
Ferrell Amy Sedaris and Kyle Gass and
they were at the same point where he was
where he literally said like you know
I'm trying to be serious and I'm trying
to like you know do you know do the do
the work like I'm supposed to but I mean
if you all want to just [ __ ] around and
have fun I'm up for that too you know
and then he started he was calling us
the Fun Bunch I mean even in the movie
he's he calls he uses that he says in My
Fun Bunch
um and then you know we all like for the
week that I was there
he would be in you know we'd all be in
the hotel bar together and one time we
were we were sitting around
uh it's very tight little tiny Hotel bar
and he comes up with this attractive
woman you know middle-aged woman then he
says hey everybody this is and I don't
remember you know this is Linda
apparently in the 80s we [ __ ]
and she was like all giggly and
embarrassed you know and he's like I
don't remember but she says we did
[Laughter]
can you imagine having that many
conquests that you're like I don't
remember uh no I have too much detail in
my brain about it